(inspiring marching band music)
- [Kayla] It is a big adrenaline rush,
just being on the field.
Seeing all those people,
you would think it makes you nervous,
but it excites you even more.
Soon as they hear the band,
everybody stops looking
at the football game,
they put the cameras on
and all eyes are on you.
Those lights flashing, cameras watching,
and the crowd goes crazy,
It's the J-Sette style.
It's not something that you
just see every single day.
(crowd cheering)
(intense drumming)
My name is Kayla Gorden,
I'm captain of the Prancing J-Settes,
here at Jackson State University.
We're very known for J-Setting.
J-Setting is a complex style:
It's a mixture of acrobatics
and African style, with
a little bit of jazz.
A lot of people compare us to gymnasts,
because we have a lot
of stunts in our moves
that most other teams don't have.
Some of our signature
moves would definitely be
the "salt and pepper."
It's kinda of where we throw
our arms back and forth.
Another signature march
we have is the "tiptoe."
You're pulling your pelvis back and forth,
and your arms are just
coming straight up and down.
The "J-Sette walk," you're
going to see our hips the most;
they look like they finna pop out.
"Bucking," and that's kind of
just popping back and forth,
at a very fast pace.
J-Setting is a word that stemmed here,
from Jackson State University
all the way back in 1971.
- My name is Gloria Tatum.
I am the founder of the
Alumni J-Sette Organization.
I am also an original
legendary prancing J-Sette.
The J-Settes were originally majorettes.
They were girls that would
march in front of the band,
but they held batons.
Shirley Millerton Blakely,
the sponsor at that particular
time, had this great idea
to bring the J-Settes to be dancers.
And so, J-Setting was born.
(quick drumming)
- [Kayla] Our training and practices
is different from other dance teams.
We run two miles under 18
minutes every single day.
We practice Monday through Friday.
And then Saturday is the game.
So out of the seven-day week,
you're with the J-Settes
six of those days.
- Four, five, six, LC.
- [Kayla] Being a J-Sette
is very competitive.
We do have cuts each week before a game.
Your spot is not guaranteed on the field.
You're going to work hard for it,
even if you're a new girl or an old girl.
'Cause old girls can get cut too,
even though you've been on the team
for two or three years,
you can get cut as well.
It's set up to make you work even harder.
J-Setting has become very influential
in different communities,
as far as the LGBTQ community,
as far as choreographers.
Knowing that a lot of people watch us,
and knowing that we
influence a lot of people-
like seeing Beyoncé, even seeing Ciara,
do like a couple of our moves-
it's very exciting because
it's letting you know
that big people like that
are really watching you.
We made a style for our own,
and we made a name for ourselves.
And lot of people know us
and respect us from that.
(horn blowing)